the outcome of interest so
what is your aerobic fitness how strong
are you how much muscle do you have
seems to be associated with
larger differences in all-cause
mortality than the actual training to
promote those things so basically having
really high levels of aerobic fitness is
predictive of a pretty large reduction
in all-cause mortality uh doing aerobic
training
is associated with a reduction in
alcohol's mortality but not as large as
the reduction uh observed with simply
having really high levels of aerobic
fitness same thing with resistance
training doing resistance training is
associated uh with reductions in alcohol
mortality rates but those reductions
don't seem to be as large as the simple
difference in mortality between
people who are just very strong in old
age and people who aren't so
you know the the characteristic is
predictive of uh pretty large
differences in mortality the actual
training to promote the adaptations uh
related to those physical
characteristics
are also associated with reductions in
alcohol's mortality but not as large as
just differences in the characteristic
itself
and so
i think that's worth noting so one like
the the stuff with resistance training
it's it's not just kind of a one-off
thing we see something very similar with
cardio as well
um
and i think that the question raised uh
has a pretty
has at least one
uh
potential and i think very likely answer
so you know if
if being stronger and having more muscle
is predictive of lower rates of
all-cause mortality um
you know why isn't resistance training
and as much of it as possible predictive
of similarly large reductions in
all-cause mortality and i think that's
just because
when you're dealing with those
characteristics you know not who's
training for what but just simply as
you're entering old age who has higher
aerobic fitness who has more muscle mass
who has more strength
i think that's more just reflective of
genetics but also lifestyle kind of
throughout your entire life so
you know if you're
um
if you hit like 60 70 you're still you
still have a fair bit of muscle you're
still in pretty good shape
more often than not that means you've
lived a generally healthy generally
active lifestyle up to that point uh and
so you know it's basically it's
basically a question of like
um urge it's a matter of
you know if you're gonna live 80 years
like the first 70 years of your life
that's
that's the bulk of your life and all of
the stuff you did during that time is
going to influence how the next 10 15 20
years for you go
versus you know if you lived a generally
inactive not particularly healthy life
for the first 70 years of your life and
you pick up some resistance training
pick up some cardio that is probably
going to be good for you but it and i
certainly wouldn't discourage people
from doing that but it's probably not
going to be quite as helpful as it would
have been
to have been more active for the
previous 70 years and so i think that's
basically what's going on and the other
thing to note
is that especially for the metas and uh
and cross-sectional studies that are
looking just at you know do people with
more muscle mass live longer than people
with less muscle mass what what those
studies tend to do is they just uh put
people into quartiles and just compare
between quartiles so how long do people
in the very top quartile of muscle and
strength live versus the people in the
lowest quartile of muscle and strength
and
getting into that top quartile doesn't
require
training like you want to be a
world-class power lifter so just think
about everyone you know in their 60s and
70s uh and just think like hey where
where would the 75th percentile of
muscle and strength fall you know like
probably a very small minority of people
you know who are approximately that age
are still legitimately super strong and
jacked like
you know
most of them like
people people who probably haven't even
lifted weights and are just like kind of
active
would probably
be be in that top quartile
um so you know that's what we're talking
about like if you're in decent aerobic
shape you have a decent amount of muscle
you have a decent amount of strength
that tends to be reflective of of living
a pretty good life up to that point and
being in good shape having more muscle
having more strength being predictive of
lower rates of all-cause mortality
doesn't necessarily imply
that training to maximize your aerobic
fitness you know like trying to set the
the marathon world record for people in
the 80 year old age class
or you know trying to absolutely
maximize muscle and strength it's it's
not necessarily implied that you need to
do those things to reap the longevity
benefits of generally being in good
aerobic shape generally having a decent
bit of muscle generally having a decent
bit of strength like there's
there's that disconnect between the
physical characteristic itself which you
know training does go into but also just
your lifestyle throughout your entire
lifespan and your genetics like all of
those things affect that
versus just the training component
itself so it's it's logical to assume
that if you
train for a
particular physical outcome and that
physical outcome itself is predictive of
all cause mortality the training itself
will be similarly predictive of
shifts in alcohol's mortality of a
similar magnitude
but that that just isn't the case